♪
STEVE: WELCOME BACK, EVERYONE.
WE’RE BACK WITH LISA, SARAH AND
CHARLIE, AND THEY’VE GOT SOME
IMPORTANT POINTS TO MAKE.
CHARLIE?
>> LOOK, STEVE, IN YOUR BOOK
WITH YOU TAUGHT ME THE POWER OF
DECENTRALIZATION AND LOOKING AT
THINGS ON A LOCAL LEVEL.
WE’RE STARTING TO SEE WHERE THIS
IS REALLY CONCENTRATED.
YOU HAVE ABOUT 20% OF THE
POPULATION IN NEW JERSEY, NEW
YORK AND CALIFORNIA,
SPECIFICALLY IN L.A. COUNTY AND
NEW YORK CITY, THEY’RE
ACCOUNTING FOR ABOUT 59% OF THE
CASES, PUNCHING WAY ABOVE THE
WEIGHT OF EVEN THE POPULATION
PERCENTAGE THEY HAVE.
I’D LIKE TO SEE MORE NATIONAL
UNITY ABOUT ASSISTING THOSE
AREAS AND ALSO RELIEVING SOME OF
THE QUARANTINE AND ALLOWING THE
AMERICAN ENTREPRENEUR TO BE
LIBERATED DAY 15 COMES, SOME OF
THE PARTS OF THE COUNTRY THAT
HAVE NOT BEEN AS IMPACTED.
THERE ARE REAL ECONOMIC
CONSEQUENCES TO THESE SORTS OF
QUARANTINES THAT ARE GOING ON.
STEVE: YEAH, EXACTLY.
GREAT, GREAT POINT.
LISA, YOU’VE GOT A REACTION TO
LARRY KUDLOW’S COMMENTS EARLIER.
>> I ALMOST JUMPED OUT OF MY
SEAT WHEN HE IS SAID POTENTIALLY
12 WEEKS.
WILL ANY OF THESE POLICY
PRESCRIPTIONS MATTER AT THAT
POINT?
BANK OF AMERICA ESTIMATES BY
NEXT WEEK WE COULD SEE THREE
MILLION UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS, SO
IT SEEMS TO ME IT’S MORE
CRITICAL FOR THE WHITE HOUSE AND
CONGRESS TO WORK WITH PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIALS TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO YOU SLOW THE SPREAD OF
THE CORONAVIRUS AND PROTECT
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES AND
INDIVIDUALS WITHOUT UTTERLY
CRASHING THE ECONOMY.
DOES ANYONE ACTUALLY THINK 12
WEEK OF THIS IS NOT GOING TO
COMPLETELY DESTROY THE ECONOMY?
STEVE: SARAH.
>> THAT’S SUCH AN IMPORTANT
POINT.
I MEAN, LISA HAS A VERY
IMPORTANT POINT HERE, AND THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION, I’M SURE, IS
LOOKING AT VERY CLOSELY,
SOMETHING THAT THEY ARE GOING TO
DEAL WITH IN THIS 15-TODAY MARK
WHEN IT COMES UP, AND IT’S
SOMETHING THEY HAVE TO DEAL
WITH, WE ALL DO.
BUT I THINK THE IMPORTANT THING,
STEVE, IS WE ALL HAVE COMMON
SENSE, WE USE THAT COMMON SENSE,
WE KNOW HOW TO TAKE A CARE OF
OURSELVES AND OUR LOVED ONES.
WE LISTEN TO THE MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS, BUT WE USE OUR
COMMON SENSE AND FIND A WAY TO
NOT ONLY CURB THE CORONAVIRUS,
BUT ALSO INSURE THAT OUR ECONOMY
DOESN’T COME CLASHING DOWN. --
CRASHING DOWN.
I BELIEVE THAT WE WILL MOVE
FORWARD AND IF WE WILL BE
VICTORIOUS IN THIS, BUT WE CAN
ONLY DO THAT WITH COMMON SENSE.
STEVE: AND JUST IN THE FEW
SECONDS THAT ARE LEFT, CHARLIE,
JUST WRAP IT UP.
IN TERM OF HOW WE CAN COME
TOGETHER OVER THIS AND STOP THE
POLITICAL ATTACKS, SOME OF THE
COMMENTARY WE’RE HEARING AS AN
EXCUSE TO ATTACK PRESIDENT
TRUMP, THAT’S GOT TO STOP, DON’T
YOU THINK?
>> IT’S NONIS SENSE.
THE PRESIDENT’S DONE A
PHENOMENAL JOB, AND HE’S ADAPTED
QUICK, IT’S A QUICK LEADERSHIP
FORM, QUICKER THAN ANY OTHER
PRESIDENT WE COULD HAVE POSSIBLY
IMAGINED.
HE HAS BROUGHT THE COUNTRY
TOGETHER AGAINST AN INVISIBLE
ENEMY, AND THE PRESIDENT WILL
MAKE THE RIGHT DECISIONS TO GET
THIS ECONOMY BACK AND ROARING IN
QUICK ORDER, AND HE’LL BE ABLE
TO ALLOCATE THE RESOURCES NEEDED
IN THIS PART OF THE COUNTRY THAT
NEEDS THEM.
AND HE WILL LIBERATE THE
AMERICAN ENTREPRENEUR.
STEVE: THANK YOU FOR THAT.
GREAT DISCUSSION TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US DO,
PLEASE, COME BACK AGAIN NEXT